[Music]
hello
you are going to always figure out what
other ways you can find that that is
more assistant that's what technology
gives you and that's why I think we need
more of your brains women aren't really
like represented as scientist or being
into technology seeing us being
represented in the media ideally done
something like this so hugely empowering
your voices are incredibly important and
need it because without your voice you
cannot make change when you're little
you're always like I want to be a
superhero
he's definitely inspiring just having a
role model before we wrap up anything
else you wanted to say any parting words
I actually one thing you guys have plans
on Monday night we would love you all to
be our guests at the premiere of a man
wasin
[Music]
all right we can't wait to see you yeah
[Music]
it's so cool I'm very excited on a scale
of one to ten my scale is broken
synchrony really could fundamentally
believes in diversity and inclusion and
girls our code is an opportunity to give
girls a chance to enter the jobs of the
future
what we can do to help them is amazing
the fact that there's a female superhero
who's a scientist you've got all the
boxes checked there and it's a role
model that a young girls can aspire to
be thank you for being the real-life
hope and I watch this
[Applause]